welcome to this video playing I'm on RD
here I'm on al-hadid ah from the Egypt
no Yemen this flex turkey okay this
laughs with queen bee three and he's
going for e63 solid way to play and
quite reliable just with Bishop e7
playing a typical Queens gambit declined
style it's um sometimes not so so easy
to do for sloth players so they tend to
prefer typical Slav setups but it's of
course perfectly okay and I want to
exchange so much not sure if this is a
good decision but do want to exchange so
much with Bishop e7
okay I don't mind him to take on a phone
this is of course a very nice structure
with the double pawn now the e file is
opened or is there is there some
sacrifice no I really don't think so
okay yeah now i can take on d5 and try
to play on this true diagonal with
tricks but it's probably not really
working anyway so i better hmm I better
play it in a more restrained way and
don't need any offensive tactics just a
long-term this position is very nice for
what really okay yeah I can take you for
take g 5 and I don't see don't see the
big point maybeee through Yong hmm yeah
I don't know this should be voice the
right move probably in any case maybe I
could have taken with the night and play
Bishop e2 well this is this maybe was
interesting this I didn't really think
about to be honest I just thought that
he would open the F file what is the
pointer eh for he is playing age 6 is
this really the point maybe
okay Queen takes I was thinking king age
to preparing 23 this useless is simply
flying completely different stuff than I
oh then I think about sometimes you
really have games where the other other
person is constantly playing different
moves than you ever expect and then at
some point I really have recommend to
stop looking for the opponent's moves
because you probably never gets them
anyway this is against such a move I
just take it and and what what now night
f1 night f4 2592 or what neither for
that it takes me five maybe maybe that's
the point I can also take a form I don't
know
yeah okay well the only thing is you
shouldn't really not plunder any peace
or something because if you don't you
just win the game rookie for maybe this
is also threatening rook e8
look the four night f-4s this really is
this really happening I don't know it's
not that's not really working but if he
goes I mean I threatening rook the eight
and half a king I've said the rookies
even pin so i really am don't see the
move okay rookie a check and let's let's
check now I mean maybe there's even
something better than just night f4 if I
play Queen h1 check what is the more
nothing I guess I can just give away two
pieces and then it's made
has very strange game i really didn't
understand how expensive any of his
moves and always always problematic I
mean g5 really maybe it's not so bad
it's just like I never really expected
it and night this is in fact better
either computer points this out this is
what I saw right afterwards this is just
a strong continuation okay but I don't
think this can be any bad I know the
other computers some plus 2 something
okay here here h4 was recommended but
this is also keeping a big edge yeah oh
yeah FYI also solve it I don't think
that Queen III can be can be any bad
form yeah night air force winning this
also wins plus 5 yeah it's always very
irritating though yeah there is they
simply know and here we have this just
forced forced winded here this forced
made yeah it's it's simply not playable
what what he did we probably met around
here blacks position is strategically
sorry around here is strategically very
dubious but he should just probably keep
this this passive setup and to try to
hold on there is really nothing nothing
much better available just yeah just
stay solid and try to hold the fort this
f5s g5 is Sam is hurting him more even
alright thanks for watching